i didn't really have a secure place to
live
um
i lived in about eight different homes
and at one point i actually became
homeless and i lived off my car in my
car off mulholland so that was really
a lot and i i was quite proud so i
didn't want to tell
anyone skipping forward to
why were you confident that you could
become an actor come to la
be in this crazy town
full of crazy people
i'm quite a fearless kind of person and
i always just
gamble on myself i guess i left home
when i was 16 to pursue the arts i left
um
england to come to l.a at 23. i watched
a a documentary about hollywood
in the studio system in the 40s when i
was about 13 years old and i just
thought it looked really magical um
just storytelling you know i had quite a
rough upbringing
you know
being bullied and just a lot of kind of
it was hard you know and i think i had
this life outside of the dark situation
in movies that was my escape and i just
kind of thought of hollywood as just a
magical land
and it really is i mean there's
obviously all the stereotypes about la
exist but i just wanted to experience it
and i've never been to america
i saved up money from my last musical
theater job
got on the plane um i actually forgot my
wallet which was so stupid so i arrived
in l.a with no wallet and my phone
didn't work and uh this lady who i
actually never met
came to pick me up and i didn't have a
phone it was a bit of a nightmare so it
was a bit of a rocky start let's say but
um
i'm kind of grateful for all the
challenges because it made me have um
perseverance and staying power and
it makes me appreciate where i am now
having a happy home life and
having a good circle of friends i had to
start from scratch when i was 23 and
that was kind of
you know it was challenging but it was
good to push myself out of the comfort
zone
did you have people pulling you back
home
friends family
um
life situations when i first moved to la
i was quite an in-demand dancer that
sounds really arrogant but i was doing a
lot of work and i was getting offers of
jobs still back in the uk so
it was hard i was pounding the pavements
here trying my best to get work and i
was getting offered work back home so
there was a bit of a push and pull
um because i did have an agent and
manager here that would getting me
opportunities but i was getting real
money offers so i did kind of go back
and forth a little bit
and then after a while they said you
know you can't you can't really be doing
that if you want to be taken seriously
as an actor you can't be going back and
doing these dance jobs that aren't
really progressing your career where we
want to take you so i kind of had to
make a choice around 27 to really
in a way you know um
quit dancing and just take acting full
time
what is the typical length of a dancer's
career
um it really depends on the style of
dancing i mean ballet's a lot younger
it could be 35
hip-hop and ballroom and stuff there's a
bit more longevity but then you can go
into choreography or teaching but being
a professional dancer the shelf life is
not long um and i i was pretty lucky
from 19 to you know 27 28 i did a
tremendous amount of
fantastic jobs and i got to see the
world i got to work with pop stars i got
to do musicals
musical movies and i just had a really
great time but i kind of ticked a lot of
my dreams off and then my dreams changed
so then i wanted to be more creative
behind the scenes or direct or you know
there was just a lot of other things
that i was interested in i'm very
inquisitive by nature so
and does it have a does that have its
own dark side to it or or it's only
positive
my inquisitive side definitely has a
dark side which i think is okay because
we have a light and dark side and i've
embraced both and it makes me
a deeper performer a deeper person it's
given me
a deeper well to pull from as an actor
um yeah no i think that being lonely in
l.a when i moved out here and
there was some negative influences that
um
i had to explore so i had to work out my
demons
you know i came here my manager told me
i had to be straight um
i was told
you know it would lose me roles being
gay and i had to kind of create a facade
and a persona and
curate a lifestyle um that was pretty
challenging because i had to kind of
play a role in my real life and i think
authenticity
is is peace is happiness um
and for about three or four or even five
years it was just a lot to keep up and i
think that that led me to a more
destructive kind of personal life
because i was kind of
feeling kind of
you know not great in who i was when
your team and people around you don't
celebrate you and it's not neces it's a
kind of old it's not necessarily their
fault it's the old hollywood mindset a
lot has changed in the last 10 years so
don't have any bad blood um
funny enough the people that told me i
couldn't be gay were gay
oh interesting yeah so yeah i was it was
a challenge um i had some luckily i had
therapy and i had a good support system
of friends and it got me through those
harder times
that's what i was wondering is is now it
seems like that wouldn't be the case but
maybe i'm wrong it seems much more
acceptable i think it is and i think
there's
it's so much more accepted um but you
know there's still people losing roles
because they're gay matt bomer lost out
to being superman he lost out to 50
shades of grey and i think it happens
all the time i think there's a lot of
actors that are still in the closet
because they might lose out on those
major roles
um you know living in l.a we're in a bit
of a bubble
um
but i think we've got to be grateful for
the progress that has happened and keep
celebrating the people that are brave to
come out and be with their authentic
self it's a scary thing
i mean not all actors want people to
know their personal life i'm a very
private person and it's quite hard for
me to talk about that but i also think
that if i can share my personal
experience and inspire others to do the
same even if theirs is different then
that's my goal to really inspire
sure and i know i you know i'm not so
much up on the tabloids but i know the
british tabloids can be quite invasive
in terms of when someone hits a certain
level and just it seems like
there's just all bets are off and it's
it's
super destructive so i could see why
somebody would want to keep their
personalized to themselves for whatever
reason just to just to preserve their
own life you know yeah i also think as
an actor you want people to not i don't
think it's
that interesting to know too much about
the actor because i want to believe them
in that role and i think sometimes if
you could become too well known as your
personality i mean look at jennifer
anderson she's a fantastic actress but
so many people know her
so so well through her personal life
they can be distracting actually i think
luckily i think she's now probably
become more private intentionally but
when you're so well known for your
your personal life um it can it can be
hard to forget that when you're watching
them on screen
sure i think well i can only speak for
myself i think when you're younger maybe
you're more open to people knowing more
about you and then as time goes on there
is a destructive element that can come
to play you did a movie called trophy
boy and i know i'm skipping ahead but it
sounds like there's some similarities in
that in that you know there's a facade
that you want the world to see but
there's a destructiveness in trying to
keep that up
yeah i think that my
i don't say gif but my one of the themes
as a writer director is exploring the
onion of taking off the mask and
revealing one's true self because that's
a journey i've explored many times and
i'm very close that as i just said so
it's something that i feel i can share
because i've lived it
um you know truth is stranger than
fiction so i felt compelled seeing the
destructive side of social media the
mental health
uh how it's affected people's mental
health i wanted to kind of showcase the
dangers of it in a
slightly comedic but heartfelt way and i
was really proud that the film i was
very nervous making the film because i
used a lot of my own social media and i
used certain elements of myself
and um
some people actually thought i was
trophy boy but i was okay with that you
know whatever like as long as you're
enjoying the work then i don't really
care
but i intentionally made it a little bit
provocative a little salacious
um
as you know you wanted to get clicks you
wanted to get talked about but i wanted
most of all to have substance and i
wanted it to be relatable a lot of
people that watched trophy boy
said they either were guilty of some of
that or they knew people like that and
um
trophy boy was a proof of concept for a
television series we're now working on
so
we're hopefully going to explore some of
these things in a deeper way on a series
so yeah i'm excited about it yeah i'd
like to see it
why were the first two years in los
angeles difficult for you um
i didn't really have a secure place to
live
um
i lived in about eight different homes
and at one point i actually became
homeless and i lived off my car in my
car of mulholland so that was really
a lot and i i was quite proud so i
didn't want to tell anyone
sometimes that kind of
yeah it was really just lonely a lot of
the time a lot of rejection
and i had this steady um three or four
years of working consistently in london
which i kind of gave up for this dream
and you know it was
it was a bit of a shock but at the same
time
it was exciting it was um
you know i believe la is a blank canvas
and it's what you make of it and even
though it was tough i kind of
enjoyed the fact i was pursuing
something i think it's great to have
purpose
and go for your dream and i just had a
gut instinct that i just had to stick it
out and gradually things got better
so when you would have auditions or
whatnot you would have a cell phone they
could leave a message
it wasn't i mean in this day and age you
don't need an answering machine you can
have a cell phone again so when i first
moved to la i had the blue book so we i
mean it was like kind of nerve-wracking
i had just driving around we didn't have
google maps on our phones
you know i didn't have the internet on
my phone i think i might have done i
don't know but we didn't you know i had
a map map so i was like so freaked out
by driving on the freeways i was always
late for auditions
um but yeah i know it was uh it was
things have really evolved now
everything's done by tape a lot of the
time
it's become a lot easier with google
maps i remember just getting freaked out
getting lost a lot of the time like the
first year was just navigating
just driving around la was even
challenging for me
sure sure there's you know like
when the light turns red at an
intersection and you're making a left i
didn't realize that there was this like
unspoken rule that those three cars
could actually make that left you think
okay it's green for me i can go right so
yeah there's a lot of things that take
use to um you know sort of navigating
when did you get your first place after
you lived in your car briefly what was
the first place that you got after that
so i got i booked a couple of
commercials i started making some money
and i got a place on sunset and hayworth
7950 sunset and i got my own apartment
which was just amazing um and then um
they got me by saying was the first
three months rent free and then you know
and i was a bit
um i was a hopeless optimist because i
thought that i could survive in that and
i remember then like six months in the
rent was really high but i made it work
and then i moved to um and then i
started getting some more jobs here and
there the commercials really kept me
going kept me afloat
and then um
then i started getting more tv roles and
i managed to get a place on laurel
canyon where i lived for six years i had
six six magical years in laurel canyon
that's when i really feel like i started
to really feel grounded in l.a
and you're in a magical place where you
know there's a history yeah did that
help at all where you felt like i've
arrived or you felt like i'm one step
from having to leave here
i felt like i'd arrived oh nice i really
did i think there was something i felt
really at home
in laurel canyon there's a magical
energy there it's a very artistic kind
of community of people
and i finally
i actually started mixing with other
producers and i wasn't just acting i was
starting to kind of go into like
behind the scenes development stuff and
that kind of gave me a bit more control
and power i felt
um i just wasn't at the mercy of
producers and casting directors i was
actually starting to create some
opportunities for myself and that really
gave me um
some encouragement that you know
it wasn't i could i could do more than i
thought i could
and at any point uh once arriving at
laurel canyon did you feel any pull to
go home did anyone try to ask you back
um
no
i've never uh
there were times i was homesick a little
bit um but i i've always kind of managed
to go back a couple of times a year to
the uk and my mum came out here
my sister has come out here multiple
times but i've never been
i've never questioned even though
there's been times that have been tough
like i actually broke my neck my i had a
minor fracture to my neck in 2016 and
for six months i couldn't move my neck i
couldn't work out i could barely drive
even though that was going on i never
really questioned my my journey i kind
of just stuck it out
as hard as it was